so you may remember back when Barack
Obama was president that there were
these conspiracy theories that were
cited with no evidence that maybe
President Obama wouldn't relinquish
control of the White House he wouldn't
leave the presidency he might try to
change the law to allow presidents to
continue to run indefinitely or he might
do something to the Constitution of
course not understanding what that would
entail
maybe President Obama would declare
martial law and suspend the 2016
election and of course there was no
reason to think that would happen
because President Obama never mentioned
anything about it there was no actual
evidence that it was something he would
do and it was very clear that there was
a full election taking place and that
Barack Obama was not going to seize
indefinite control of the Oval Office
still insanely unlikely that Donald
Trump would do something like it but in
contrast to under Barack Obama Donald
Trump has actually said after China
changed the law to allow the president
to continue running Trump said
president-for-life sounds pretty
interesting maybe it's something that we
would do here in the United States in
the future
Donald Trump has implied before that if
he were to lose a presidential election
it could only be by fraud you might
remember that during the 2016 election
he was actually asked if you lose will
you accept the results and he said well
we'll see not even willing to say yeah
if I lose I lost and then to add to all
of this Donald Trump's own former
personal lawyer Michael Cohen said
during his testimony last week that he
fears Donald Trump will not peaceably
transfer power if he loses the 2020
election let's take a listen to that
clip and I will not sit back say nothing
and allow him to do the same to the
country indeed given my experience
working for mr. Trump I fear that if he
loses the election in 2020 that there
will never be a peaceful transition of
power and this is why I agreed to appear
before you today so tons of people
emailing me saying how could a president
even try to stay in power like how could
he try not to leave
who would actually remove him so let's
actually play it out there's a few
primary scenarios here so let's take it
seriously let's deal with it once and
then we can sort of move on the first
example is like the simplest one imagine
that there's some kind of psychotic
episode a mental health thing where
Trump is refusing to leave but is not
coherently contesting the results of the
election and his administration's not
contesting it that's the simplest
situation I think Secret Service just
removes Trump maybe with with mental
health professionals like I don't think
that that's really the most complicated
scenario I also don't think it's the
most likely scenario what we're really
talking about here is that the election
is closed maybe it's contested and
ultimately Donald Trump as well as his
administration and staff decide they
don't believe Trump actually lost you'd
have a president elect you'd have that
president elect in touch with the FBI
and the Secret Service and the Justice
Department and the Joint Chiefs of Staff
of the military and there would be a
physical removal of the president period
it's insane it's crazy but in a
situation like that that's how it would
go down but that gets us to the
importance of the military and again I'm
doing this because people are emailing
about it I'm doing it because Michael
Cohen suggested that it would happen
last week not because I think this is a
likely scenario authoritarians being
able to stay in power often comes down
to support by the military if we talk
about Venezuela for example ultimately
whether Nicolas Maduro stays or goes
could come down to whether the military
backs Nicolas Maduro if indeed the
military backed Trump not leaving power
then you are all of a sudden talking
about a coup d'etat right a coup by the
state is that likely I don't think so
this is something that is often said
about other presidents they're never
going to leave the White House they're
going to refuse to relinquish control
and it's bogus and here it's also
probably bogus the differences we have
Trump statement about
maybe accepting election results we have
Trump's statement about it sounds pretty
good president for life and we have
Michael Cohen's statement here so Pat
for the good of the country I hope that
it never actually comes to this but I
think that those are the ways that it
would play out if it did come to that
point in time I can't imagine that if
there is a decree from a Supreme Court
or from a Federal Elections Commission
or whatever that Donald Trump has lost I
don't know how the military supports
Trump just staying in power I think that
our system of checks and balances here
in the u.s. is strong enough so that
even if Trump decides that he's not
going to concede it won't matter at the
end of the day because he'll be taking
out one way or another but I don't think
it'll come to that because Trump has
shown signs that he's willing to cave
when he knows that he's lost like on
family separations and the government
shutdown recently so I don't think it'll
come to that he may refuse to attend the
inaugural of whoever defeats him but I
think that's about it yeah I think the
most likely scenario is that this is not
a thing but since Michael Cohen
mentioned it and there's actually more
to to make us think about it than with
any recent president I can think of
we've talked about it that's how it
would work and now we can move on to
bigger and better things I want to have
with you today what I hope will be an
adult conversation a serious
conversation and it's a conversation
where I want to put aside sort of the
partisan politics of evaluating how the
current administration is faring it's a
separate discussion from any particular
political issue it's a separate
discussion from the perception of Donald
Trump internationally which happens to
be very embarrassing but that's not what
I actually want to talk about today we
have to start really thinking about the
Trump mental health concerns that are
increasingly prevalent and a topic of
discussion we did a number of interviews
over the last year-and-a-half
sort of generally about this we did an
interview about Donald Trump's mental
health deteriorating with dr. John
Gartner we did really that interview got
more than half a million views clearly a
topic that resonated with a lot of
people we did another interview where we
had a psychiatrist indicating that
actually Donald Trump's mental condition
is dangerous we did an interview where
the focus was on the impact of Donald
Trump's narcissism and how that presents
a danger in terms of thinking about his
role as president of the United States
and this is a serious enough issue where
every time we talk about it more and
more mental health professionals get in
touch with me and they say yeah David
you really need to keep talking about
this so we're actually working on
getting dr. John Gartner back on the
program because unfortunately and I do
say this seriously I'm honest when I say
it's unfortunate there's evidence that
this is getting worse and Twitter last
night another indication of the
instability I don't know if we we say
it's it's mental illness or cognitive
decline but it's certainly the erratic
emotional instability of the president
lashing out in a series of tweets and
retweets targeting even relatively
unimportant people in the grand scheme
of things for example Tom Steyer a rich
dude who's been talking about impeaching
Donald Trump for a while nice guy I'm
sure successful in his career but in the
grand scheme of things it's not super
clear why Donald Trump cares that much
about Tom Styer Donald Trump last night
tweeting quote weirdo Tom Steyer doesn't
have the guts or money to run for
president he's all talk behavior very
unbecoming of the President of the
United States of America
Donald Trump also last night retweeting
an article from the Washington Examiner
I just totally outrageous right-wing
publication it was Don it was a Donald
Trump jr. post which Donald Trump
retweeted and once again the Jim Jordan
the guy who is quoted in the article a
completely disgraced and not credible
extremist right-wing Republican and
again why is Donald Trump doing this why
is this what he's spending his
I'm doing we don't know then retweeting
Don Jr's post of an article from the
straight-up conspiracy website Zero
Hedge suggesting a conspiracy about
British intelligence officer former
British intelligence officer Christopher
Steele who you might remember was the
researcher on the Trump Russia dossier
another Trump enemy and then tweeting
about a dude named hans von Spakovsky
from the right-wing heritage foundation
known for his efforts to suppress voting
via all sorts of voter ID and other
rules that he supported his dad happens
to be Russian doesn't seem particularly
relevant to our conversation today
Donald Trump they're tweeting that Hans
von Spakovsky has said he's not seen
evidence that Donald Trump has violated
the law and suggesting that Adam Schiff
is like a modern-day Joseph McCarthy of
course Adam Schiff the Democrat in
charge of the House Intelligence
Committee this is not the pattern of
someone who is thinking clearly this is
not a rational person under any
circumstances but this is no random
Twitter troll right this is the
President of the United States is he
taking on the behavior of a trapped rat
trying to figure out whether to abandon
ship and drown in the ocean or wait it
out and ultimately go down with the ship
and that that is where increasingly my
attention is going this noose of
criminality is closing around Donald
Trump two-thirds of Americans now
believe that Donald Trump is a criminal
I'll get to that polling data
momentarily and Trump is now straight up
doing his Richard Nixon I am NOT a crook
tweeting just a couple of days ago quote
I am an innocent man being persecuted by
some very bad conflicted and corrupt
people you know witch hunt that is
illegal and should never have been
allowed to start and only because I won
the election despite this great success
innocent people normally welcome
investigations that will
innocent people want investigations that
will clear them to be carried out
without interference and without
obstruction so that they can be cleared
they don't do everything under the Sun
including committing more crimes to stop
those investigations this is not the
behavior of an innocent person but more
importantly this is not the behavior of
a mentally healthy or stable person and
we're going to be talking to dr. John
Gartner about this again coming up
pretty soon the Conservative Political
Action Conference known as CPAC was held
this weekend we're going to be looking
at a bunch of different clips from it
will start with clips from Donald
Trump's speech and then later we'll get
to a whole bunch of other speeches and
panels that took place it'll be sort of
up to you to figure out what's the
wackiest of the entire gong show but
when we think about the Trump speech
first I want to call your attention to
the fact that in many ways Donald Trump
is becoming more and more authoritarian
obviously there's the cozying up to
other authoritarians and being hugely
impressed by people like Vladimir Putin
and Kim jong-un and fighting more and
more with our allies like France and
Canada and Germany and we've talked
about the attacks on the media as the
enemy of the people
there's the mention that he's made
before of liking the idea of maybe
allowing president for life in the
United States the way that China has
moved in the direction of doing there's
the dismissal of all facts and the
creation of completely fact free
narratives that make Trump sort of
authoritarian and I could go on but a
really interesting trait that Trump is
adopting is longer and longer speeches
and this is just a classic authoritarian
move Fidel Castro was known for endless
speeches in Cuba Putin has done
five-hour call-in shows Hugo Chavez and
Venezuela would ramble on and on for
four or five six even eight hours in
some cases and there's a couple
interpretations of why authoritarians do
this one is they genuinely believe that
people are interested in hearing from
them for that long it's sort of like a
narcissism and I think Trump has no
shortage of that
another point of view on long
authoritarian speeches is that it's a
way to control the public right you're
not going to get up and leave during the
great leaders speech and it's a way to
exert control over the population
another idea is that when authoritarians
sense that they're in trouble or that
there are threats they go longer and
longer in their speeches and you could
certainly argue that Donald Trump's
presidency is under threat right now in
any case that gets us the CPAC over the
weekend and Donald Trump gave a record
long speech more than two hours long and
he absolutely lost it in front of a
crowd of total sycophants first Donald
Trump coming out hugging the American
flag which is just this total sideshow
thing that he's done a few times now
[Applause]
yeah by the way the country music I have
to comment on the country music how dumb
and gullible are you to believe that
Donald Trump a rich guy who grew up in
New York City and wants everything
gold-plated how dumb and gullible do you
have to be to believe that he now likes
country music and identifies it as a
Republican and I'm curious whether
people agree with me
I believe that privately this is a
completely this is a persona Trump knows
is totally bogus
I believe that privately Trump knows
that hugging a flag is stupid but he
also knows enough to realize that the
CPAC audience absolutely loves Trump
hugging a flag and they do they actually
think it's extraordinary and they went
completely bonkers
so then Trump gets into his actual
two-hour speech and he goes after Robert
Moeller in an unhinged tirade Trump
swears in the clip and by the way just
so everybody knows it's okay to air this
this is no one's gonna get fined by the
FCC for airing the president's words
take a listen to this unfortunately you
put the wrong people in a couple of
positions and they leave people for a
long time that shouldn't be there and
all of a sudden they're trying to take
you out with [ __ ] okay
oh man in the crowd just loving the fact
that the president is not going to
kowtow to political correctness he'll
swear if he wants to swear
of course what he's saying makes
absolutely no sense he appointed most of
the people that have been involved in
one way shape or form and saying
everything that's going on in terms of
the investigation is totally aboveboard
and legal and constitutional then Trump
just starts making things up about
immigration and listen to the bizarre
claim he makes about birth control here
but mothers who love their daughters
give them massive amounts of birth
control pills because they know their
daughters are going to be raped on the
way up to our southern border think of
that true story told to me by the Border
Patrol yeah massive amounts massive
amounts of birth control pills how is he
this dumb either you're taking birth
control or you're not right massive
amounts as if taking more than the
prescribed amounts are effective in some
way and then maybe most cryptically most
disturbingly Donald Trump claimed during
this two-plus hour-long CPAC speech that
he is going to be signing an executive
order requiring colleges to support free
speech what does that even mean we don't
know Trump obviously doesn't know but it
didn't stop him from saying it now it
said I will be very soon signing an
executive order requiring colleges and
universities to support free speech if
they want federal research
reaction and that of the crowd suggests
everybody knows what this means but
nobody has any idea what it means Trump
doesn't know what it means what does it
mean that he will sign an executive
order requiring the support a free
speech I was thinking back and actually
watched over the weekend some old CPAC
videos there was a time when CPAC was
actually about conservative ideas there
were ideas I disagreed disagreed with
vehemently but they were ideas that you
could argue in the sort of spirit of the
Hegelian dialectic or of having
different views a sort of yin-yang we
need a force that is for progress and we
need a force that prevents us from going
too far too fast right you could have
some sort of more neutral point of view
on the idea of a party that is for
moving forward and changing everything
and a party that says let's be a little
cautious I can get behind the value of
conservatism in that sense even though I
would disagree with the ideas this is no
longer that okay CPAC is propaganda it's
red meat it's the weaponization of
ignorance and I saw a tweet over the
weekend that really sort of exemplified
how we should be thinking about this
this is like trumpets CPAC for two hours
is like a crazy guy screaming on the
subway for two hours except the guy has
access to nuclear weapons and that's an
extraordinarily scary thought but it's
the reality that's the reality we're
working with and the reality is an
increasingly erratic unhinged
unpredictable but also authoritarian
Donald Trump I have to hand it to Chris
Wallace on Fox News he now has a fairly
extensive repertoire of solid interviews
with Trump officials where he just
doesn't let them get away with their BS
I've talked about the failings of our
debate system earlier in the show our
presidential debates are a format that
doesn't really allow for follow-up it
doesn't really allow people to be forced
into more specifically defending their
claims or to be called out when they
make conflicting claims Chris Wallace
actually does a good job of this
sometimes on Fox News
this gets us to this weekend where
Donald Trump's a war hungry national
security advisor john bolton who spoke
to chris wallace and tried to defend
Donald Trump's behavior and actions
related to Kim jong-un
now remember Trump's first summit with
Kim jong-un in Singapore miserable
failure nothing came out of it Trump
declared victory that the nuclear threat
is over of course nothing actually
happened after that they have a second
summit this time in Vietnam Trump goes
gets nothing the negotiations end
without an iota of progress Trump
praises Kim jong-un says he takes him at
his word about not knowing about how
American otto warmbier was being
tortured Trump eats it all up and it's
an international embarrassment every
single time that Trump praises these
dictators and shows that he's totally
dominated by them it is an international
embarrassment Putin said he didn't medal
and he seemed serious when he said it
but he's a great guy and he's a strong
guy Kim jong-un says he had no idea
about warm beer but he's a really bright
and funny and remarkable guy and were
having a great relationship together so
chris wallace calls out john bolton
about it and he says hold on a second
Trump believes this stuff and john
bolton goes into a word salad stutz
that's that stuttering all over the
place completely incoherent and bolton
tries to say that i take him at his word
just means i believe that this is what
he said which of course is of no meaning
take a look this is not the first time
that the president has taken the word of
an autocrat over outside evidence not
taking word he said I'm gonna take when
he says I'm gonna take him at his word
it just it doesn't mean that he accepts
that his reality means that he accepts
that's what Kim jong-un said so when he
says I take him at his word it doesn't
mean that he believes Kim jong-un well
that's what he said I think one way to
prove that is to give the United States
a complete account okay so take him at
his word doesn't mean I believe him it
just means he believes he said this
which means nothing since they were in
the room together similar situation on
CNN but there they play another
important part of what Trump said not
just the I take him at his
third part but actually I don't believe
that Kim jong-un would have allowed this
to happen
how does Trump know that apparently
because his relationship with Kim
jong-un is so great I want to play with
President Trump said about Kim jong-un
and the brutal mistreatment of the
American college student otto warmbier
who was arrested in North Korea and
returned to the United States in a coma
and he subsequently died take a listen I
don't believe that he would have allowed
that to happen he tells me that he
didn't know about it and I will take him
at his word he's gonna take Kim jong-un
at his word that he didn't know about it
the warmbier family put out a statement
they disagree they say Kim jong-un is
responsible are they wrong look the
president made it very clear he
considers what happened to otto warmbier
an act of brutality that's completely
unacceptable to the American side I've
heard him before the summit itself
before the press conference talked about
how deeply he cared about otto warmbier
and his family the fact is the best
thing North Korea could do right now
would be to give us a full accounting of
what happened and who was responsible
for him well Trump believes it was
brutal what happened how is that even a
statement what does that even mean I
don't believe that he would have allowed
it to happen he does this stuff all the
time Kim jong-un is known for doing
exactly this type of stuff all the time
and Bolton says the best thing would be
for Kim jong-un to give us a full
accounting of what happened why is that
the best thing for Kim jong-un Kim
jong-un convinced Trump that he knew
nothing about what was going on without
a warm beer and that he certainly had
nothing to do with it
he already convinced Trump why on earth
would Kim jong-un now give us an actual
full accounting of what happened to otto
warmbier there's no incentive whatsoever
for him to do that since he already
convinced Trump and Jake Tapper tries to
follow up on this
do you take Kim jong-un at his word the
president takes him at his word yes but
what about you my opinion doesn't matter
my opinion is that I've secured of hours
with the president underscored a bit I
am NOT the national security
decision-maker that's his view a total
cop-out
more importantly Bolton is one of the
most hawkish clowns of the last 15 years
of neocon American politics when bolt
does these milquetoast defenses of Kim
jong-un you know the entire order of
things is just backwards and it really
seems as the Bolton was brought in to be
a sort of neutered version of himself
under Donald Trump that's actually not
all bad because a neutered John Bolton
might actually prevent his war hungry
nature from convincing Trump to start
more Wars it's just very strange and
hard to understand a genuinely bad
stubborn guy who appears totally
dominated by the Trump regime of idiocy
and cognitive dissonance I'm curious as
to why although anything that prevents
more Wars from being started is
something that in total I have to admit
is good make sure you're following the
david pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show where you can vote on
upcoming show topics and check out some
of the behind the scenes pictures by the
way that I have up on my Instagram page
at david dot Pakman we'll take a quick
break the conclusion to my interview
with the very homophobic dr. Paul
Cameron is coming up next
so that's Trump at CPAC let's now talk
about everybody else at CPAC just to
sort of close the loop on it closing the
loop on the weaponization of ignorance I
have a clip for you that is a mere 72
seconds long where there are five people
competing for the dumbest comment of the
entire weekend at CPAC on stage you have
Donald Trump jr. you have Charlie Kirk
from Turning Point USA you have Donald
Trump juniors I guess his girlfriend
former Fox News anchor kimberly
guilfoyle
and then two other clowns I think I
think one guys match slap and then some
other woman you don't even have to know
who they are but they are all on the
CPAC stage trying to be clever CPAC 2019
set the record for the dumbest comments
that the crowd went absolutely bonkers
for a quick note a lot of lip service
paid to guns at CPAC of course it's a
gun-free zone no guns
loud why because it would be insane to
let's at thousands of conservatives
carrying guns into a room with each
other obviously so all about guns no
guns allowed at CPAC that gets us to
some of the panel's check out this first
video and tell me who do you think is
the dumbest here three weeks ago
tomorrow we had our second granddaughter
and like I said a few weeks ago yeah
and her name is Reagan how presidential
is that beautiful Reagan Elise I lobbied
for Trump but it was a little too soon
maybe so we'll see Trump is not the most
feminine name that we could make it the
liberal playbook it doesn't matter you
know it doesn't matter we can identify
how we want okay so I mean I guess you
can call your kid whatever you want
obviously I guess the joke is that it's
a reference to trans people existing and
that I guess counts as funny during CPAC
on the C PAC stage in front of that
crowd so now we continue with this new
grandmother explaining gender to the
crowd by the way she is a daughter she's
our granddaughter she's a dame we're
raising her as a girl she's we're not
letting her have a choice
she's outraged tomorrow that you decided
for God God makes the choice of what the
babies are gonna be and God decided she
would be a girl you know so this is just
straight-up transphobia right I mean
this is this is a dumb conversation it's
a very stupid conversation
and by the way she's gonna have a choice
I hate to break it to you someday she'll
be an adult and she'll be able to make
decisions for herself unless you
literally enslaved the girl so now it's
getting very very dumb like this out
does Donald Trump jr. but then I think
it gets even dumber than what Don jr.
said but it comes from the other dude on
stage take a listen
you don't have to raise them as a girl
she just got a little baby doll right
right there are every second when my
boys always have guns in their hands
we didn't that's not something hashtag
me too that's not something you teach
them that's something they're born with
but as far as those cows you mentioned
I've got a hundred cows you just let a
Alexandria Cortez show up at my house
and try to take my cows away yes I love
cows Jerry they're delicious
yeah so that guys that's Jerry that's
not match slap I don't know who that guy
is is that Jerry Falwell Jr I don't even
know I have no clue who that guy is
but what he's saying is if a baby holds
a doll they will be a woman and his kids
held guns so they are men and then he
talked about what Alexandria Cortes I
don't know who that is
Alexandria Cortes referring to a OC
obviously a OC recently said it would be
better if everybody ate fewer burgers
and now there's this meme that
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez wants to take
people's cows and it's a real Sophie's
Choice here trying to say who said the
most ignorant stuff here and I don't
know Pat whether the most disturbing
element of this is that CPAC chose to
make this a panel or that CPAC was right
the audience would love it and they did
I think the most disturbing element is
that Donald Trump jr. thinks he's the
comedian now like we know from the
Michael Cohen testimony that Trump
thinks that his own son has the worst
judgement of all time I think that comes
true that rings true when he's trying to
make jokes there and they completely
fall flat other people had to fake
laughs in order for it to keep going
yeah I mean just sucking the air
directly out of the room so that's that
panel but that's not all then we get to
this outrageous congressman mark meadows
who literally brought in a black woman
as a political prop during the michael
cohen hearings he opened up also by
talking about alexandria Acacio cortez
conspiracies and chick-fil-a you know
with this green new deal they're trying
to get rid of all the cows but I've got
good news
chick-fil-a stock will go away yeah more
chicken all right I mean so okay and
then Ted Cruz also talking about killing
cows which really seems to miss a o'seas
point altogether obviously I hope to see
Peter supporting the Republican Party
now that the Democrats want to kill all
the cows
[Applause]
chicken and beef now the subject of CPAC
chicken and beef really an entire
weekend of idiocy weaponized ignorant
cognitive dissonance and unfortunately
people who came away feeling invigorated
this stuff I've been to conventions like
this people experienced this stuff and
they come away invigorated like it was
just the most amazing experience it's
almost like a spiritual experience for
people who attend and they now come out
strengthened their beliefs strengthened
that their harebrained ideas and
completely backwards logic and morality
is the way forward and I would not be
surprised if it actually leads to more
erratic behavior in the real world not
just from the people who attended but
also from the speakers because you go
out there and you see this rabid crowd
hungry for transphobia and jokes about
socialism and communism and all this
stuff they come away like wow our
movement is really something we are now
going to get even wackier in the real
world and that's already what you're
seeing in the short time since this
event I'm on Twitter if you want to send
me your thoughts what exactly is the
defining characteristic of CPAC in your
mind I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
we've been talking about the increasing
role of Fox News in the amoral fiasco
that is the campaign and presidency of
Donald Trump and I've got two Fox news
stories for you today shortly a second
story on today's show we've learned that
Fox News actually had the stormy Daniels
story which includes multiple crimes for
which people have now been convicted
before anybody else had it before the
election of President Donald Trump and
for political reasons they killed the
story they didn't run it that's going to
be the second story on today's show but
before we even get to that there are now
allegations that Fox News actually gave
Donald Trump debate questions in advance
of the debate that they hosted back in
2015 and before I give you the details
it's really important to understand the
context here okay room
remember that the right went crazy when
it was alleged that Democratic a DNC
staffer Donna Brazile passed a potential
Town Hall question to Hillary Clinton
and it's a question mark whether it was
really even a question or a topic now
either way it was wrong to do that
as a DNC staffer that supposedly is an
unbiased arbiter of the Democratic
primary what Donna Brazile did is wrong
it shouldn't have happened but the right
went bonkers and it may have been
dealing just with a topic rather than a
question and in fact Trump specifically
raged against CNN when that news broke
you might remember that in the first
debate that Fox News did in 2015
however there were so-called tough
questions from megyn kelly and there are
now two Fox News insiders plus jane
mayer whose investigative work on this
has just been absolutely touched top
notch who say that Roger Ailes who at
the time was the Fox News CEO told the
Trump campaign what the questions would
be from megyn kelly during that debate
now I want to be really clear here
there's a lot of informational spin
happening around this there are
counterclaims saying that actually
Donald Trump wasn't really given
anything he wasn't even getting along
with Fox News Channel at the time so why
would they want to help him
there are counterclaims that Donald
Trump was given questions in advance of
the debate but they ended up not being
asked they were either questions that
were dropped or they were bogus
questions questions that were never
going to be included and then there are
also counter claimants that yes someone
fed Trump questions in advance but they
were asked by other people than it
wasn't the quote tough megyn kelly
questions that he was fed that's not
really the most important thing here
okay so let's go through this in a kind
of logical methodical progression first
of all is it possible or even likely
that Donald Trump was fed questions in
advance of the Fox News debate of course
right megyn kelly even
said so two years ago that that's not
actually the notable thing Trump still
performed like a [ __ ] but it was the
type of [ __ ]
that some Republicans loved enough to
ultimately make him President of the
United States it wasn't because he was
fed questions from Fox that he became
president despite being fed questions he
still made a fool out of himself and it
didn't matter because Republicans voted
for him anyway so that part is actually
less interesting as far as Fox News is
concerned yeah Fox is the propaganda arm
of the Trump administration today almost
exclusively yeah Shep Smith is an
outlier Chris Wallace is an outlier but
feeding questions to Trump would be both
not surprising and also not even
necessary for Fox to be what they are
today which is a de facto mouthpiece for
the Trump administration with Sean
Hannity at the top of that sort of
hierarchy of propaganda what's the real
issue here the real issue for me is that
this is another opportunity for me to
mention that the way these debates are
set up doesn't help us figure out who
the best candidate is that's what
debates should do and that's not really
what the story is about but in a way it
is because whether or not the questions
were fed to Trump candidates knowing the
questions ahead of time is a very small
piece of why these debates are BS in
total these debates are structured in a
way where the only outcome is that you
either do the Trump thing which is
insult people and say things about Rosie
O'Donnell and other people little Marco
and Rand Paul's physical appearance and
call people note low energy and try to
score point that way or you try to score
points by just listening talking points
because fundamentally the debates are
structured to have weak moderators in
almost all cases and in most ways they
are way too short in terms of how long
each person is allowed to speak to get
into any substance and that's maybe as a
result of the low attention span that
many news consumers have at this point
and it's just too easy to give up which
means just throw a whole bunch of stuff
out there
miss state the positions of your
opponent sir was claimed that your
opponent is misstating your positions
and nothing substantive actually happens
here's one example not even from the
Trump era the first Mitt Romney Barack
Obama debate MIT Romney spent half the
debate claiming that Barack Obama was
simply mischaracterizing his points of
view in his positions even though Barack
Obama was accurately characterizing Mitt
Romney's points of view in positions and
it avoids any real and substantive
debate but it's not even fully exposed
because the format is too short to even
really let us hash that out here's an
example of a specific topic where we
often learn nothing taxes okay when
candidates debate taxation it's we
should cut taxes for the middle class or
we should raise taxes for the very rich
everybody needs to pay their fair share
we are overtaxed get into exactly what
your brackets would be what would the
percentage of marginal tax rates be and
debate why that's the plan that you want
because if you actually allow the time
for that to happen it will be very
obvious which candidates don't have the
slightest idea with what's going on
which is a lot of them it would be
surprising how many of them that is you
need real-time fact-checking that has to
be something that is done it's not
partisan it's merely reality you need to
empower the moderators to be stronger
both parties often will negotiate to
weaken the role of the moderator by
limiting what the moderator or
moderators are allowed to do what we
have and I get it we started with Trump
got questions ahead of time okay what we
have are debates that if anything dis
inform people about actual issues and
they encourage a total lack of critical
thinking and this is just the first Fox
News related story for today let's now
go into the second one okay so today I
want to have a conversation with you
about the facts of the 2020 Democratic
primary the fact is that right now today
March 4th Bernie Sanders
is the Democratic frontrunner for the
2020 Democratic presidential nomination
period okay now let me be clear about
what this story is not this is not a
story of me endorsing Bernie Sanders
I've not decided yet who I'm supporting
in the 2020 Democratic primary I've said
Bernie is among my top contenders but
this is not an endorsement of Bernie
Sanders this is not a story about who
should you support or who is ultimately
going to be the nominee this is merely a
story about the fact that if we want to
assess who the front-runner is as of
today it is Bernie Sanders and I am
going to tell you exactly why in a
moment now it's also important for me to
remind you things can and often do
change in the point during the period
between 16 months prior to the election
and the time that the Democratic
National Convention takes place we're
about 16 months from the DNC in the
summer of 2020 that's when the
Democratic candidate will officially be
named very frequently the front-runner
in March of the year before is not the
eventual nominee things are very
different now of course than they have
been in the past but that's just sort of
a word of reality that right now it's
very often difficult to know who is
ultimately going to be the nominee
I believe that Bernie Sanders is now the
frontrunner along three different lines
number one name recognition number two
polling and number three fundraising
when you look at those three categories
in concert Bernie Sanders is the
undeniable frontrunner so let me lay it
out for you first and then we'll kind of
talk about the implications will start
with polling when it comes to polling
polling isn't everything
polling isn't always exactly accurate
but taken in the aggregate when we look
at polling before Bernie declared that
he was running and after Bernie declared
that he was running Bernie Sanders is
the front-runner out of the candidates
who are officially part of the race now
why am i mentioning that last part
because of Joe Biden okay Joe Biden is
actually winning most polls he's
not a candidate right now if he becomes
one then we will have to revisit this
but if you look at a list of recent
polling that has been done the morning
consult poll has Bernie ahead with 27%
remember there's like 10 plus candidates
the d cy fo r poll has bernie at 14%
that's actually in the lead out of the
candidates that have declared the
Harvard Harris Poll has Bernie at 22%
the Harris X poll has Bernie at 12%
ahead of Kamala Harris by only one
percentage point that's from before
Bernie even announced his candidacy the
morning consult poll from February 17th
also from before Bernie even announced
had him ahead at 21% and Emerson College
from before Bernie announced also had
Bernie with a plurality of support at
17% out of the candidates who are
running it's important to know that in
all but one of these polls Joe Biden is
ahead of Bernie Sanders and in some
cases significantly so even though he
hasn't declared his candidacy we're
going to get back to that at the end of
this story
so that's polling polling isn't
everything okay what about crowd sizes
crowd sizes also aren't everything but
being able to be a primary candidate
this early on and garner significant
crowds is an important thing
Bernie Sanders held his first rally over
the weekend in Brooklyn massive crowd
outdoors in the cold on a day that it
had been snowing off and on an estimated
crowd size of 13,000 so that is also a
point that we should be considering but
we know crowds can be deceptive and
don't actually tell you that much what
does tell you a lot an hour system is
money fundraising Bernie Sanders raised
more than three million dollars in the
first eight hours of his campaign that
more than doubled Kamala Harris's entire
first day he's expecting to hit 1
million website signups of people who
want to be either participating in the
campaign or kept up-to-date on news
the campaign and his fundraising
fundraising is absolutely off the charts
that's a really really important factor
and then lastly his name recognition and
this is a really really interesting one
because if you think back to 2016 Bernie
Sanders had relatively low name
recognition yes he was known to people
who had political shows like the David
Pakman show
he was known to people in the Northeast
disproportionately but he did not have
significant name recognition and in part
that's probably why he was really
working uphill for a huge portion of the
campaign just to get anybody on
corporate media to even pay attention to
him contrast that to now the beginning
of the 2020 election process of the
people already running today
is there anyone we can say Pat has the
name recognition of Bernie on the
Democratic side other than maybe
Elizabeth Warren I mean I can't think of
anybody else it's not Booker it's not
camel Harris I was gonna say that it's
not camel Harris I don't think it's
Booker it certainly is an Amy Klobuchar
I think Bernie Sanders is number one by
a longshot I believe at this point
Bernie Sanders also has the name
recognition advantage in this primary so
I don't think that there is any
substantive case to be made that there
is a different frontrunner at this point
in time on March 4th of 2019 than Bernie
Sanders now that's the situation today
how can things change
what are we paying attention to to see
where this is going to go going forward
as I mentioned before number one usually
the front-runner in March of the year
before the election doesn't end up being
the nominee that's a historical argument
historical arguments against Donald
Trump were made and they failed so
that's merely a historical argument that
says Bernie is not going to be the
ultimate nominee but everything is
different in the era of Trump number 2
Joe Biden if Joe Biden enters this race
I believe he's instantly the
front-runner based on current polling I
would actually expect more support for
Joe Biden if he ends up declaring
because as we saw with Bernie when
Earnie formally announced his candidacy
his support went up in polls and Joe
Biden is doing really really well in the
national polls number three what is the
role of the DNC going to be here we know
that there are different degrees that
people claim the DNC affected the 2016
primary there are those who say they may
have preferred Hillary but ultimately
she got millions more votes than Bernie
anyway and we can't say that it was
merely because of the DNC that Bernie
lost there are others who say Bernie
would have been the nominee were it not
for the DNC whatever your position is on
that issue there's an open question as
to in what ways will the DNC get
involved in the 2020 Democratic primary
and number four and maybe most
importantly remember that there are
foreign and domestic efforts to create
infighting among Democrats and among
supporters of the different Democratic
candidates we can't allow that to
succeed the media even despite its best
efforts if we're charitable covers
Bernie in a way that they play into the
idea that he's bad for Democrats that
he's bad for the left we don't know what
Bernie versus Trump would mean we don't
know who would have won in 2016 had it
been Bernie versus Trump and I can
assure you that people in corporate
media definitely don't know what the
meaning of Bernie versus Trump would be
so that's kind of where I am on this
right now Pat one side note is as far as
Elizabeth Warren goes and as I mentioned
she's one of my top contenders for who I
would support her campaign is in trouble
and I've been reading some op eds that
suggest her campaign may be far more
short-lived than initially imagined as a
combination of how she handled the
Native American DNA situation which was
a fiasco and more generally her poor
interviewing skills I don't know where
you are on this Pat but I'm reading more
and more stuff that suggests Elizabeth
Warren simply is not going to go the
distance
yeah Elizabeth Warren is going to be
fighting for the same group of people
that Bernie Sanders appeals to and I
think Bernie Sanders comes across as a
lot more
likeable a lot more authentic he's been
doing this for longer serving in
Congress for quite some time and I think
he would have the advantage there over
Elizabeth Warren who's more prone to
gaffes probably not as likable and is
not as progressive at the end of the day
so get me your thoughts about the
Elizabeth Warren thing but most
importantly here's what I want to hear
from the audience about if you can make
a fact-based an empirical case for
Bernie Sanders not being the
front-runner today I want to hear from
you right so that would be a case to
understand it's this can't be Bernie's
not even a Democrat and I don't like him
okay that that's not what I'm looking to
hear from I know we'll see lots of those
comments on YouTube on this video what I
want to hear from you is David here's
where your facts are wrong
about polling fundraising and name
recognition that's one possibility
or David your facts are right about
polling fundraising and name recognition
but here's what you didn't mention that
explains why Bernie Sanders is not
actually the front-runner right now
that's the that's what I want to hear
from people and if we get some good
explanation some good defenses of
someone else being the front-runner then
I'll bring them to you later in the week
and we can continue the conversation
about it make sure that you follow the
David Pakman show on Instagram where we
will be letting you vote on upcoming
show segments the show is on instagram
at david pakman show and while you're
there follow me as well at David Pakman
scandal breaking out over the weekend on
my Instagram I posted a picture of
myself eating a burger and as I'm I'm
known to do I eat burgers what is by by
the traditional consumers of burgers
known as upside down and a complete
crazy battle has broken out on my
instagram page over the burger fiasco am
i eating it upside down am i not is it
good to eat burgers upside down anyway
you can debate it if you follow me on
instagram at David Pakman the more
serious topic here is Bernie Sanders
being the front-runner for 2020 and I
look forward to hearing from you about
that